- I give up. (laughs)
Way too difficult.
I just stood there next to her
and I couldn't do anything.
I couldn't even speak to her.
Oh my god, Eric!
Come on!
Hey guys, I'm Eric.
I recently moved to New York,
and it's a little hard
to make friends here.
Everyone's always in a rush.
People are hard to talk to.
I don't know.
I feel like I'm, maybe it's my fault.
I feel like I'm intruding
or like I don't know what
to talk to people about.
I just don't feel like I'm
connecting with anyone,
so I'm just gonna break my wall,
and I'm gonna try to
make more friends today
by talking to 100 strangers.
Huh, this is so scary, okay.
Eric,
you can just talk to people.
How's it going, man?
Hey man, how's it going?
Is it cool if I sit here?
Oh, cool man.
I'm just trying to meet people.
You play chess?
You don't, no?
Quiet lunch?
Alright, dude. It's good, it's good.
I'm Eric. Nice to meet you.
Don't talk when people are eating?
Okay, okay.
I'm sorry. Nice to meet you, though.
Who do I talk to, man?
I don't think anybody wants to talk to me.
Hey guys, what's up?
Are you guys from here?
Yeah? I'm new.
I'm sorry to make this awkward.
I've been here like two months.
Trying to make friends.
So I'm literally just going to the park
and, like, talking to people.
It's really awkward.
Yeah, really?
Awe, you guys are the best.
Alright, I'm gonna do it.
Eric, nice to meet you.
I moved from Philly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is it cool if I sit down?
Perfect.
What are you reading?
What's that about?
Are you guys-
Yeah, sure.
Where are you guys from, Israel?
No way. I just went on Birthright.
Is it cool if I watch?
Oh, dude, thank you guys.
Can I hear a poem?
Yeah, man.
How did you get in to juggling?
Where do you go to school?
Oh, that's awesome.
Design stuff?
That's crazy.
I don't think I've ever
met a butcher before.
Whoa.
Jesus. Oh my god.
You're smart as hell.
I'd love to sometime, maybe
take a lesson or something.
Do you guys have cards?
Or just, I'll find you.
Yeah, let me get your number.
How did you decide to
just start like this,
like writing poems on the street?
No I have not.
Yeah.
Dude, this is gettin' easy.
I'm getting good at this.
The next few hours were incredible.
I met so many interesting people
and I hope this video
can lessen the stigma
behind talking to strangers
because it truly is eye-opening.
I mean, strangers fed me a bagel, okay?
And there was just so much
positive energy and joy.
Everyone was laughing, having a good time,
and I ended up adding
100 people on Instagram,
who I genuinely want
to stay in touch with.
I know this is getting cheesy,
but I experienced something awesome,
and I hope everyone can see how much love
this world has to offer.
I just feel like I'm in
love with strangers now.
I just want to talk to
strangers all the time.
Just like, how's it going man?
Yay! Good, good, good.